"Everyone is listening to you now.
You came by the tens of millions to become
part of a historic movement the likes of which
the world has never seen before..."
US President Donald Trump's victory is part
of a new wave of Populism sweeping through
the democracies of the world.
What differentiates populists from mainstream
politicians is the claim that they alone represent
the will of the people as a whole.
That allows them to dismiss any opposition
to themselves or their policies as an attack
on the popular will.
Modern populists often take this approach
as they tap into the backlash against immigration
and a globalized economy that many voters who feel
left behind.
Here's the situation.
Unlike most ism's, populism does not lean
left, right, or even center.
From the late radical socialist Hugo Chavez
in Venezuela to the far-right nationalist
Marine Le Pen in France, the uniting factor
is how they conduct politics.
According to one author there are three core
requirements for politicians to be considered
populist.
One: they make an appeal to the people, championing
their cause against a despised elite.
"She will keep our rigged system in place.
I alone can fix it."
Populists also use crises, or manufacture
them, to justify the call to revolt.
And lastly, inflammatory language is used
to shock the establishment and prove the politician's
credentials as one of the people.
"There is a lot of moroccan scum in holland
making the streets unsafe."
"Mr. Obama, you can go to hell."
The 2008 financial crisis opened the door
for populists, as rising inequality eroded
trust in politicians and other powerful members
of society.
Here's the argument.
Because populists make big promises to shake
up society, they tend to bump up quickly against
democratic checks and balances, in particular
the courts and media, that are designed to
limit what governments can do.
the temptation becomes to
declare these institutions part o fan elite
conspiracy to block the people's will.
"I have a running war with the media.
They are among the most dishonest human beings
on Earth."
There is a reason why populists emerge.
They promise a correction for democracies
that seem to have lost their representative
power and they offer a fresh start.
The challenge remains for mainstream politicians
to address widespread economic and cultural
fears.
Otherwise the draw of populism is not going
away anytime soon.
Anything is possible if enough decent people
are prepared to stand up against the establishment.
Thank you very much indeed.